on ne remarque plus l'architecturé
grandiose de la gare de train de lviv et
les noyés par un raz-de-marée de
passagers destination l'exil la paix
tous en mode survie à peine capable de
penser à l'instant présent ils ont les
traits tirés le visage trempé par les
larmes de regard absent
il faut encore se frayer un chemin
patiente est souvent plus de 20 heures
pour monter à bord des trains vers la
pologne
certains c'est déjà trop demain ils
n'ont pas la force ou l'envié d'y penser
j'ai du mal à expliquer ce que je
ressens dit ruslana je me sens trahi par
sept autres pays les enfants n'ont rien
fait pour mériter ce qui se passe c'est
juste cruel c'est ce que je crois c'est
de la cruauté de la trahison progresse
elle et ses filles me lanier paris ce
reviendrons ruslana refuse de monter à
bord pour un aller simple
svetlana son mari et leur fils espérait
aussi prendre un train pour la pologne
mais on leur bloquent le passage s'ils
insistent pour partir tous les trois ils
n'iront nulle part
l'homme ils m'ont dit que je devais
défendre mon pays dit sergueï mais
comment si je n'ai jamais tenu une arme
dans mes mains je n'ai pas fait mon
service militaire à la frontière de la
pologne on nous attend pour nous
conduire en espagne
c'est de l'anah est anéanti
il ya ceux qui partent mais il ya aussi
ceux qui arrivent dix vingt trente mille
personnes passent ici tous les jours ce
qu'ils étaient il ya une semaine à peine
une place publique relativement désert
s'est transformé en véritable village de
la solidarité
un repas chaud hein tu es une sucrerie
c'est le moins que pouvait faire ces
femmes elles ont des amis des parents
coincés dans les zones de combat
accueillir ceux qui ont pu fuir leur
apporte un peu de réconfort
natalia acheter des provisions pour les
faire cuisiner par un ami restaurateur
et
pour moi c'est dur de les voir forcés de
quitter leur maison je suis chez moi ici
je peux faire quelque chose pour aider
d'autres ne peuvent pas parce qu'ils
arrivent ils ont très peur ils ont fait
la route pendant 30 heures en se tenant
debout les enfants allongés à 3,4 sur un
siège mois et tout le monde on vient d
comme on peut yab vont y changer
c'est ce qu'ils peuvent contribuer à
l'effort de guerre ça va aussi conduire
à la victoire dit volodymyr love l'amour
c'est notre arme la plus puissante dit
il est avec les peuples européens et
tous les gens dans le monde qui croient
en ukraine nous allons gagner
ailleurs au pays c'est tout sauf de
l'amour qui servent d'armes la caméra de
cette voiture a capturé une explosion
dans la ville de tchernihiv et les
survenue dans un quartier résidentiel
près d'une école et d'un hôpital selon
les secouristes sur place plus tôt dans
la journée c'est un réservoir d'huile
qui étaient en flammes le bilan est
lourd au moins 33 morts selon les
autorités
volodymyr elin ce qui continue d'appeler
l'otan a imposé une zone d'exclusion
dans tout l'espace aérien de l'ukraine
en vain les toits houston iah si nous
n'existons plus alors dieu nous en
préserve la lettonie la lituanie
l'estonie seront les prochaines dit il
puis la moldavie la géorgie la pologne
ils iront jusqu'au mur de berlin
croyez-moi le monde doit montrer sa
force sans se battre sans perdre des
gens car la force c'est la diplomatie ni
n'essaie de pour moi
en soirée une lueur d'espoir les russes
et les ukrainiens annonçait s'être
entendus pour un cessez le feu partiel
pour permettre des corridors
d'évacuation de la population civile et
l'acheminement des aides humanitaires
il serait grand temps pour car kim qui
brûle toujours depuis trois jours la
cité d'un million et demi d'ukrainiens
suivi l'acharnement des missiles et des
obus de la russie le centre ville n'est
plus que débris on cherche et on compte
les morts maria fait ce qu'elle peut
pour documenter ce qu'elle décrit comme
les crimes de la russie
[Musique]
je suis épuisée dit elle le stress est
constant et quand je peux enfin dormir
mais seules pensées mon rêve c'est que
ce n'est pas en train de se produire ici
à kharkhiv je vais me réveiller dans une
ville comme il ya une semaine qui n'a
pas été bombardés où la guerre n'a pas
commencé
non mais c'est un cauchemar éveillé que
vivent les résidents ici un cauchemar
que mohannad a mis presque trois jours à
fuir étudiants libanais étaient à deux
mois de compléter ses études de médecine
un rêve anéanti
why
did i
do
tout ça pour de la politique dit il des
enfants et des femmes tués chez eux la
guerre au liban n'a jamais été si cruel
croit-il c'est là qu'il veut maintenant
retourner la crise y est telle que le
liban fait naufrage mais vu d'ici il
ressemble à une bouée de sauvetage
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada les
vivent